j'avais commencé à vous raconter une
anecdote plutôt une histoire qui est
arrivé et qui aurait pu mal se terminer
pour moi on est le 13 septembre 2007
jetons la rue je marche et je me dis je
vais traverser alors identifié un
passage piéton témoins et au moment où
je mets le thé sous la chaussette waouh
en étant de klaxons déchire l'air je me
sens dans une surprise jeunes retiennent
précédemment je me retrouve sur le
trottoir la voiture a juste devant moi
je réalise j'ai failli passer à côté de
l'accident je suis passé à côté de
l'accident en fait j'avais pas vu alain
retière qui arrivait j'avais pas vu non
plus de passages piétons
j'avais identifié et pas du tout un
masque répond mais en fait c'est vrai
mais en effet de serre et les garçons
j'ai terminé de lumière fois et j'ai pas
vu tout ça parce qu'effectivement
j'étais aveugle comme vous voyez sur
l'écran là haut et pourquoi j'ai fait
cette expérience là c'est parce que
simplement j'ai derrière moi kate apple
et je me suis dit qu'on aime raconter
son histoire il m'a dit voilà je suis
tombé ce soir au niveau du rer pour ça
qu'ils prennent le bus le train vous
savez des fois ya une séparation pour le
train bloqué sur le mal sont bien mais
ça fait une chute d'un mètre soixante
années 70 à peu près elle n'aura rien je
vous rassure mais sa marque et je me
suis dit waouh c'est bizarre watchguard
la robotique j'ai fait des petits robots
la coupe de france de robotique qui
tombe pas des tables comment ça se fait
qu'on fait rien pour les urnes
aujourd'hui
alors j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit un
bleu - montigny robles que je peux faire
pour ça et la première étape qui me
semble logique essayer de se mettre à
plat de l'autre
donc voilà je me suis mis à eux en une
semaine en septembre 2016 vous encourage
si vous voulez faire de saxe cobourg
minutes graisses saturées
c'est intéressant et je vais partager
aujourd'hui justement 3 découvert ce que
j'ai fait durant cette semaine qui m'ont
vraiment inspiré pour les broyages
jusqu'à présent et vous avez un problème
dans un voyage voyage ensemble
je vais bien voir sa manche que je dis
devant ma semaine classique
sinon volume certainement un gros et on
a quelque chose de conserver les yeux et
pourra parcourir ensemble un trottoir en
région parisienne et 200 le trottoir lui
on à l'immeuble dont vous venez de
sortir se trouve à votre droite à gauche
vous savez galante vous donnez votre
main dans la main droite
vous sentez le dallage sur gautier on
est en plein été une ferme où sont tes
qui ferment des dénicheurs détendue un
léger vent de face vous intense le
mawlid une terrasse de café où l'on vous
sentez d'achat du soleil seront bras sur
votre visage
c'est vraiment agréable mais tente un
pas après l'autre on marchait votre
canne faire d'incessants cisaille devant
vous pour vous éviter tout obstacle
entendre doute à faire de très belles
nous assure que murray toujours d'un à
droite et que vous marchez d'un bras
gauche un bruit très fort décharné cher
c'est nous vois tu rien passé
honnêtement le bruit est tellement fort
vous avez roulé sur le trottoir du bon
dîner à marcher en mes chances vous
écartez doucement de fumeurs pour être
davantage au centre de trottoirs et
elles prennent libre de mongongu quand
toutes les autres cas le blocus de la
vente outre quelque chose de très fort
d'après le dessus ça vous évoque quelque
chose de boisés verrait peut-être un
tronc d'arbre fait pas tout à fait avec
la membrane effectivement ça ressemble à
un tronc da et maintenant fait
l'attention
goûter et koro vous en prenez les
petites routes de tête s'accorder
modestes iat sont bouclés des arbres le
long du trottoir à gauche mais aussi au
centre de jeunes ont laissé contourner
l'âme vous mettez bienvenue trottoir on
parle d'un accident et vous prenez votre
route 3 pas ça n'est pas et donc de
nouveaux venus dans quelque chose cette
fois-ci c'est vraiment métalliques
c'est un petit objet à s'ériger vous
tapotez dessus les grilles à mais c'est
ok mais vous savez ce que c'est c'est
une chaise votre chat est bloquée et de
certainement encastré dans une terrasse
de café ouvrira les yeux ça va se
terminer
et même si c'était le cas face de chez
moi
sympa même si ça a un côté et figurez
vous que je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais toute la description des
fêtes s'est réuni l'été que sur une au
jo du bruit du sombre de sensations
inodore et pourtant je suis convaincu
tout le monde ici avait une
réprésentation c'est clair dans sa tête
on avait imaginé des choses et bien
imaginer c'est intéressant il ya des
images le cerveau cette faculté de créer
des images à partir des souvenirs qu'on
avait on avait tous des routes
différentes en tête mais qui sont en
fait des projections de ce qu'on a déjà
vécu là que j'ai fait pendant sept
semaines
je pense être dans le noir et bien non
je me suis rendu compte que je voyageais
dans mes souvenirs
non mais mieux que je connaissais par
exemple j'étais très à l'aise on est le
passé et pour être vraiment serein ça
chauffe pour les objets qui ne rate et
c'est ça qui est intéressant maintenant
je manque d'un projet j'y pense je me
dis des fois je pense que je suis pas
capable de choses que ça va être
horrible non loin est en fait n'en a
plus de ressources vraiment chose de
ressources que se comprend maintenant ça
comme ses limites si jamais quelqu'un
bouge la table j'ai vu où elle est c'est
un scooter garé sur l'autre voire je
vais être désorienté et c'est là qu'on
pourra faire appel à quelque chose de
très précieux m'a demandé de l'aide vous
savez la théorie de darwin
elle est parfois un peu mal comprises on
se dit en fait l'évolution c'est une
sorte de compétition
dans la concurrence entre espèces en
vérité c'est pas du tout ça il faut
qu'on se rappelle notre société
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce que la
succession pour qu'on réussisse
c'est parce qu'on a réussi à troubler
coopérer agir ensemble ces salles
accueillent en fait c'est ce que j'avais
ouvert entre graf
durant cette semaine c'est la deuxième
ouverte qui m'a vraiment marqué c'est
que je me suis rendu compte de la
faculté très fort de l'être humain à
bâtir avancé de cette empathie naturelle
qui prend le métro ici ok on l'avait
versée
roblin des décès dans son téléphone
regards se croisent surtout par monolith
et on se dit même ça se trouve signant
l'accident je n'aime pas ces capteurs
relever la tête pour les merengues
bon bah ça croyez moi ça change
complètement en situation de détresse à
un collègue l'a raconté après avoir fait
ses dents le carnaval puisque nous chez
panda une tradition ou aux employés qui
arrive doit faire le trafic
il me dit cerneaux cette expérience ça
m'a vraiment redonné foi revenais fort
l'humanité je crains de me le dire
quelque chose
j'ai eu des situations des tracts sur
une semaine je me suis rendu compte de
la bienveillance région autour d'elle
j'aime bien raconter une gt dans le
souterrain dans une guerre à finir je me
suis un petit peu pour n'est
complètement même et unique où je dois
en haleine gilles sur bout du bruit et
il savait à ce moment là vous pouvez
vraiment perdus ou attentif à tout le
moins de rethel le moindre bout ce
mandat elle me donne pas on et termine à
peine la personne n'exclut pas où on
sent les odeurs et c'est là j'entends
des voix
donc je dis excuse moi et pearl jam et
une dame s'approche naturellement elle
jamais d'elle et elle fait ça mais bon
est-ce que vous allez être celle d'un
ascenseur
il est grand des villes quelqu'un rentre
et il vient se mettre là à 50 cm 2
vous l'avez global malaise on n'est pas
très maxime la société on aime bien au
fond des spas son confort l'âge de ma
force et ma pas me déranger
j'ai un peu comme ça moi et
paradoxalement je dis ça change tout
quand elle m'a pris la main
moi ça m'a fait le bouffer de d'énergie
de douceur de tendresse était incroyable
et je vais montrer justement cette seule
cette expérience que j'ai vécue
donc là je suis dans la gare on voit sur
l'écran que je suis en train de me
déplacer avec bruce 30 ans et l'a pris à
la droite elle même prend la main tout
naturellement mais selon certains
documents comme ça lessard de maintenir
les gens sentent qu'ils sont
bienveillants la sernam au premier étage
elle m'indique note simple ruisseau et
tout mais quelle place à des gens dans
la rue qui m'indique aussi sa tronche de
région jamais parle elle même tous les
jours et à tous les chemins boueux et
vont m'aider je puisse allah vous rendez
vous parce que durant toute la semaine
je l'étais déjà d'être travail normal et
c'était pas du tout
des fois on joue c'est un projet en
lançant le projet on a tendance à se
dire faut chaque fois je ne me reposerai
propre force cris accroc ça fait du bien
de se rappeler qu' il n'y a pas que moi
et à d'autres personnes autour qui sont
aussi bienveillante et des fonds on
tombe vraiment sur des gens qui peut
amener un prix voler ses nobles un
bordel ça ça détend on pensait aussi que
dans 3 des découvertes c'est pour moi
c'est la plus importance je relève un
type de contexte
quand j'étais du coup dans cette somme
les premiers jeux sortis sur les pas du
tout ce qui allait se passer
je suis revenu aux braves on verra bien
après avoir tapé long des murs et des
portes lettres perdues mettre fin au
niveau du jeu sur une bouche à incendie
a pointé un incendie à la m sentis
abandonnés avoir eu peur alors lancement
d'une des sections de chiens
avant mon nexus accepte au vert
précédant sert pour le moins les gens
qui regardaient sans les relents des
gens ayant manqué de me faire écraser
pour une accent j'avais vraiment parfait
et franchement le lendemain quand j'ai
mis mes chaussures j'ai déterminé je
voulais plus du tout et alex et c'était
atroce
aujourd'hui cochon à la vidéo vous et
montrez j'ai la boule au ventre
la note c je pense que c'est un
traumatisme en raison malgré tout j'en
tire quelque chose de vraiment très
important très intéressant le premier
pas c'est toujours le plus difficile
mais c'est aussi le plus important dans
cette salle où s'entremêlent de la série
je m'habille la caméra je laisserai un
ascenseur j'arrive devant la porte de
l'événement il m'est arrivé de bloquer
jeu par commune en mai un certain temps
un père matthieu rougé tétanisé qui veut
d'ici je sens j'ai encore vu john atroce
ça dure un certain temps et puis
rajeunit d'employés et je fais le
premier par les poufs c'est parti le
premier pas c'est ce qu'ils lancent tour
est la seule chasse macro et ça je pense
que c'est une à découvrir que j'ai
découvert je pense c'est la peur
disparaît ce jusqu'à son retour mais on
est né ce soir en prison
l'action s'affiche aujourd'hui comme moi
je danse quelque chose que l'on se soit
fait
on verra bien je pense quoi et je pense
que c'est un bon état d'esprit vous
reste pour terminer j'ai finalement fait
l'expérience qu'elle paie assez au début
est assez froide c'est un espace un peu
chiante ils ont longé niort je me lance
dans un truc on verra je me découvrir
des techniques comment j'allais voir me
guider en arabe etc
et j'ai découvert complètement autre
chose je me suis rendu compte à quel
point est ce que en fait finalement j'ai
découvert des choses sur moi et sur
l'autre j'allais mourir c'est trois
choses voudrait parler tout à l'heure
voir le fait - après de ressources qu'on
le croit souvent on se rappelle bien si
je me prends des voix petit est en fait
y'a des ressources en interne qu on peut
activer 2 0 peut comporter la
coopération de ses clefs et ça débloque
beaucoup de situations aujourd'hui
j'essaye par exemple à mon niveau des
peuples entendu quand quelqu'un s'avance
on compte sur quelques chansons aux
aînés j'essaierai cette personne
troisième point le premier pas cm plus
du lin et c'est le plus important
chez honda on a une devise saute on
saute c'est l'acronyme est la première
lettre d'hier sacrifice sacrifices c'est
toujours le premier est nécessaire quand
on veut sauter pan de vie j'aime
beaucoup aussi cette devine une première
rumeur dit qui ose gagne support à vue
ont de nous en conscience à zone de
confort il se passe toujours quelque
chose si je n'ai pas osé faire ça je
pense que je n'aurai pas découvert
aujourd'hui tout ce que j'aime le
couvert j'aimerais vous laisser avec une
citation d'un grand homme
notre charte sharks norris il ya
vraiment un héros en chacun et chacune
entre nous on a tout cédé design est
créée pour mettre une bénédiction pour
beaucoup est un héros pour quelle raison
mais on n'a qu'une seule façon pour
aller dans cette direction
faire des choses difficiles le
rembourrage trouve ça ça ne me dit plus
tôt j'encourage tous à faire le choix
d'être euros versés bros
[Applaudissements]